thank you very much indeed for coming
along tonight today uh it's um a
pleasure to be able to have welcome so
many people to this meeting um do have
we got any apologies for absence for the
meeting at
good afternoon chair uh we have no
apologies for absence and do we have any
any disclosures of interest um that need
to be
declared none and then the minutes um
now the minutes um I wasn't present at
the the last minutes they these were
done quite a while ago um so we have to
I think note them and and and confirm
that we've you know rather than make any
comments ourselves because none of us
were
present so accept the minutes under
those conditions
uh and then then item four which is the
main item for today is the grant for
local needs housing scheme in broom and
the officer who's able to introduce us
to this is Lisa Davis would you like to
kind of explain what all what the item
is about and maybe also introduce the
fact that we've got some visitors
today thank you chair yes so the item is
a request for Capital grant funding uh
for a local housing needs schem team in
broom um if I can introduce the guests
first of all um Sarah Brook Taylor from
war rural community council Neil gill
from war Rural Housing Association and
Richard mugglestone from war Rural
Housing
Association so the bid before us is um
from war Rural Housing Association to um
part fund a local affordable housing
needs scheme
um so I can sort of go through um and
draw out a few bits of the
report
yeah just the main PS because I think
we've all read them but it it' be nice
to be able to particularly if people
looking in to be able to understand a
little bit about the what we're we're
discussing today yeah um so the scheme
is for nine affordable homes in
broom um it is a local need scheme so it
will be providing affordable housing to
meet an identified local need and that
local need has come from a housing need
survey
um so this will be phase two of as as
sorry asple close um phase one was
completed in
2017 um and phase two um has come
about on the back of another housing
need survey um commissioned by the
parish council and warshire rural
warshire rural community council Lyford
Country Homes um and the parish council
have worked in Partnership over the last
six years to actually bring this scheme
forward so the nine affordable homes
will provide six social rent homes and
three Shar ownership and includes four
Bungalows um and just as stress that it
is the scheme is meeting um an
identified local
need the requested is £ 351,000
this equates to
19% of the estimated total scheme cost
um which is equivalent of £ 39,000 per
unit um just to stress that the the
scheme overall be financed from
borrowing from wer Rural Housing
Association um their own subsidies from
their own reserves and also Capital
grant funding from homes
England um just to stress with this
scheme the sort of sustainability um
credentials um Watcher rural are hoping
to um provide uh a scheme um an
excellent scheme in terms of its
environmental and sustainability
credentials um it will reduce the scheme
will reduce carbon dioxide emissions and
reduce energy bills for residents uh
there's a number of um sort of proposals
in terms of the green infrastructure
includes air source heat pumps um solar
panels and also importantly and the
first time for warsha Rural um there
will be solar batteries uh to enable
unused energy to be stored um which
obviously is going to help the residents
and their bills in terms of the um
Financial
considerations um should members um be
minded to approve the bid um it will be
financed from from Grant already held um
within the
council
um and
also it will be
um yeah we will be signing a grant
agreement under our normal terms as
well so in in other words it's a scheme
that will be nil cost to the
council and the way we um sort of um
allocate the funds is we will do our
usual um in that we look at um the
closest uh the funds that we have um
which to date are approximately 4.1
million pounds um we look at the closest
used by date um and yeah and to ensure
that um any terms in the section
106's um they allow the the spending of
that money on this
scheme
yeah that's probably a synopsis uh thank
you um I was particularly impressed by
the fact that you amongst your
sustainability you were talking about uh
a energy performance certificate of at
least B and that you going to be um it
is proposed that there'll be National
Space standards because there's been
some houses that have been built to less
than that um so that that wasn't and
that the council will enjoy um 100%
nomination rights in perpetuity which is
again something that uh I was pleased to
see uh do we have any comments um any
other questions to put to wara rural
housing um from from members of the
cabinet that are here
today uh well it's more of a comment the
question but I'm sure you can fill us in
the the sustainab sustainability is
really impressive um I think you you're
setting the standard here aren't you um
have you found it difficult to meet that
in comparison to other schemes that
you've been involved
with yeah is this is essentially where
the the bids coming from it's it's the
cost this additionality of of providing
the green infrastructure is where a lot
of the cost is and and where we're
directing a lot of the bid funding to
support that additionality because it is
a very is is very expensive to to
provide um that even still over and
above building
regulations
which is something that um people like
the rtpi have been aiming at you know
supporting the idea that we should be
going Beyond part L of the building
regulations but at the moment we're
waiting for different legislation to
come from National level but you have
the ability to do that under your own
schemes could I ask a question because
um there was actually an interesting
radio program on this morning uh I know
the difference but a lot of people don't
realize the difference between uh social
rent uh and a affordable rent uh and
these are genuinely social rent could
you just explain what social rent is
because say a lot of not a lot of people
understand that there is that difference
between affordable rent and social rent
that's fine chair affordable rent is
defined as 8% of Market open market
rents um and that could in effect in a
lot of cases be above the local housing
allowances for qualifying um housing
benefit applicants where social rents
typically around about 60% of Market
rents looking at looking at generally so
averaging about 20% lower than four-door
rents as I understand it as well social
rent is is B was originally based on
sort of incomes Etc but in a high uh
expensive area such as ours um trying to
make sure that people can genuinely
afford the to to live in these homes I
think is is essential so I I I've looked
through it and I haven't got any
particular questions but councelor
Curtis have you got thank um I think it
looks like a great scheme um I just want
when you the agreement will include
local connection criteria I wonder if
you could just give a little bit more
detail about what those criteria might
be so it's the uh standard criteria as
set down through SDC policy so very
briefly uh people who currently live in
the parish uh previously lived in the
parish but wish to return people who are
born in the parish people who currently
work in the parish and they'll have a
set number of hours and length of time
in employment and then people who have
local family who are living in the
parish and again within a certain time
period so it sounds per SDC policy thank
you I mean I I'm minded to um definitely
support this but what the question I
would ask is once these are done could
we have can I have more really
uh what what kind of plans have you got
to be able to go further than this after
after the broom um we've bu sorry to
inter um we have recently um received
planning permission for 10 affordable
homes just 10 affordable in isolation in
claven and that's we're just in the
process of of going through with what
the section 106 agreement um and as it
stands we're just going out to the
market for build costs so I will be
prepared ing a bid shortly again to come
back to um yourselves for another you
know ecos
scheme councelor Curtis yeah no I mean
it's been of some sort of concern to me
that we've got over4 million pounds
sitting uncommitted for affordable homes
and yes like council's unit I'd like to
see more of these schemes coming forward
because we want to be able to invest
that money in Better Homes and then
following that we're hoping to go for
another for planning um in the next
couple of months a scheme in ellswood as
well similar local needs scheme so that
will be coming through next year
hopefully would you like to yeah just
worth noting chair that the board are
meeting in two weeks time um to review
the Strategic plan for the next five
years um and there is a commitment still
to develop obviously Stratford is a key
partner of ours so um we're try to look
at 60 units in a fiveyear period um that
we can develop um but it's not just the
existing uh it's not just the new units
we we're committed to developing looking
after our existing stock as well
obviously we've got hundreds of homes um
across Stratford and we are investing a
lot of money into those to bring them up
to EPCC and eventually up to Net Zero so
there's a lot of investment of our our
funds going into bringing homes up to
EPC St standards as well but there is
still the commitment to to new build
development I I know that you know as we
go forward with our local plan uh we are
this is a kind of area that we are very
keen to um you know involve a lot all
the kind of um social housing providers
in in trying to Pro to do high standard
affordable homes we have before us then
um unless anybody's got any other
questions that you want to raise one
simple um set of
recommendations um one number one is
that the award of the grant as described
in this report be approved and that is
for the um 351,000 from from our Capital
Grant um from our capitals uh Finance to
um to to underwrite this and then the
second one is that the council's capital
program be amended accordingly now have
I got approval for that can I have a pro
proposer councelor Curtis proposed
councilor Li call second
okay and um happy to approve I'm happy
to approve so thank you very much indeed
that's wasn't a very long meeting but a
very successful one so thank you very
much indeed for your time okay
bye